die mitte europas im wandel der zeit
ein land das lange braucht um eins zu
werden
menschen die sich erst im laufe der
jahrhunderte als deutsch verstehen
wer sind wir
woher kommen wir
fragen an die geschichte der deutschen
die bbc
martin
für die republik
knapp entgeht er dem tod im krieg
umso mehr wird er den frieden lieben
karl der vierte kaiser und könig aus
prag
die rivalität mit den fürsten will er
beenden
doch er ist ein herrscher in schwerer
zeit
die pest tötet ein drittel der deutschen
august 1346 in der nähe der
nordfranzösischen ortschaft chris i
es sind 500 deutsche ritter die mit dem
französischen könig in einer schlacht
ziehen
gegen die engländer die anspruch auf
frankreichs krone erheben
auch zwei könige aus deutschland sind
erschienen der gerade ist gekrönte karl
der vierte und sein blinder vater johann
von luxemburg
die engländer vertrauen auf die
gefürchtete durchschlagskraft ihrer lang
mögen
als der kampf beginnt geht nicht nur ein
gewitter über dem schlachtfeld nieder
auch ein pfeil hagel von 5.000
bogenschütz
die gepanzerten krieger können ihre
schlagkraft nur im nahkampf entfalten
die distanzwaffen haben sie keine chance
chris iva zum debakel für die franzosen
und ihre deutschen verbindung
karls vater lässt sich trotz seiner
erblindung in das kampfgetümmel führen
und findet den tod
für frankreichs könig dem er treue
geschworen hat
der sohn wird nur leicht verletzt
als sich die niederlage abzeichnet
drängen seiner leibwache zur flucht
das überleben des jungen monarchen ist
wichtiger als der krieg in frankreich
karl ist seinem vater nur widerwillig in
das militärische abenteuer gefolgt er
hat genug sorgen in deutschland karl der
vierte ist zwar gewählter könig doch er
muss um seine anerkennung kämpfen
das heilige römische reich um die mitte
des 14
jahrhunderts drei mächtige adelsfamilien
die wittelsbacher habsburger und
luxemburger konkurrieren um die krone
die luxemburger sind mächtig denn sie
herrschen auch in böhmen
einen monat vor der schlacht von chrissi
haben die deutschen kurfürsten den
luxemburger karl zum könig gewählt
von trier wen willst du zum könig ich
wähle karl zum könig
war ja auch teuer genug
kontakt wer gewählt werden will muss
tief in die tasche greifen
auch karls weg zum thron ebenen
bestechungsgelder aus dem väterlichen
statuten
die ehrwürdigen kurfürsten des reiches
haben ihre stimmen abgegeben und ihre
wahl getroffen
sie haben karl einstimmig zum könig
gewählt
ist eine eilige wahl in rings am rhein
und nicht wie üblich in frankfurt am
main
die eile hat einen grund was hier
geschieht ist ein politischer umsturz
denn deutschland hat bereits einen könig
und der residiert in münchen
ludwig der bayer seit 1314 gewähltes
oberhaupt der deutschen ein erbitterter
gegner des papstes
er hat sich ohne dessen segen zum kaiser
krönen lassen
damit hat ludwig die erzbischöfe im
reich gegen sich aufgebracht deren
vertrauen kann genießt
sie haben diesen car zum könig gewählt
der tages will mich zum teufel schicken
und diese haben musikalisch sein
werkzeug
aber wie können ein böhmischer haase
einen bayerischen löwen erleben
die deutsche geschichte des mittelalters
ist dadurch geprägt dass könige von den
fürsten von den adligen gewählt worden
das führte allerdings dazu dass in
krisenphasen diese adligen einen könig
auch absetzen oder 1 gegen könig erheben
konnten das ist insgesamt mehr als zehn
mal passiert und führte in der regel zu
bürgerkriegen die unter den beiden
königen denn jeweils ausgemacht werden
mussten
wer im reich regieren will braucht
rückhalt bei den fürsten den geistlichen
und weltlichen
dieser aber fehlt dem luxemburger um
unbehelligt in seiner böhmischen heimat
zu kommen
reißt er inkognito als kaufmann
verkleidet durch das reich
karl ist ein könig der deutschen der
sich vor deutschen fürsten fürchten muss
das ist schon ein elendes geschäft könig
zu sein habt ihr vertrauen
vergesst nicht ihr seid von gott berufen
berufen
meine berufung habe ich in klingender
münze bezahlt ich bin der könig ich bin
ein kaufmann
das reicht durch das karl reist ist eine
welt im umbruch
während des 13 jahrhunderts wächst die
bevölkerung von 10 auf 14 millionen
menschen
riesige ackerflächen sind den wäldern
abgetrotzt worden und in den städten
wachsen gotische kathedralen in den
himmel
zeugen einer kulturellen und
wirtschaftlichen blüte
der aufschwung ist nicht zuletzt einem
sehr milden klima zu verdanken
doch um 1300 verändert sich das wetter
dramatisch
sintflutartige regenfälle
wissenschaftler nennen den damaligen
klima einbruch auch die kleine eiszeit
es sind jahre ohne sommergetreide
verfault auf den halmen um erstellte
sind die folge
der himmel scheint sich gegen die erde
verschworen zu haben
im juli 1342 wird deutschland von einer
katastrophalen überschwemmungen
heimgesucht
die städte an rhein main und donau
versinken in einer flut von biblischen
dimensionen
tausende menschen finden den tod
die flut von 1342 gilt als die größte
überschwemmung in der geschichte
mitteleuropas an allen großen flüssen
wurden sämtliche brücken weggerissen
in den chroniken wird berichtet dass
eine man im mainzer dom das wasser bis
zur brust gestanden haben soll um sie in
köln habe man mit boten über die
stadtmauern fahren können
es müssen unglaubliche wassermassen
gewesen seien und man kann sagen die
wetterbedingungen um die mitte des
vierzehnten jahrhunderts waren extrem
schlicht carlo viertel lebte in einer
sehr schwierigen zeit
es dauert nicht mehr lange dann sind wir
dort sei die unsicherheit aber ich kann
mich nicht ewig dort verstecken nicht
verstecken
mit gottes hilfe werdet ihr prag zur
hauptstadt des reiches machen
ihr dürft die zuversicht nicht verlieren
und dann heißt es
braga
kaputtreden
prag die residenz und hauptstadt des
königreichs bühnen
auf der burg dem hradschin kam karl 1316
zur welt
die krone des königreichs böhmen hat
johann der blinde durch eine heirat land
nach seinem tod geht sie auf karl über
diese krone kann ihn im reich niemand
streitig machen
unter den herrschern seinerzeit feld
karl aus dem rahmen
er ist hochgebildet und spricht mehrere
sprachen fließend
im alter von 30 jahren verfasst er eine
autobiografie auf latein mit dem titel
das leben karls des vierten ein privates
dokument wie es von keinem anderen
herrscher des mittelalters erhalten ist
minutiös schildert er einen albtraum der
ihn lange beschäftigt denn träume
enthalten für mittelalterliche menschen
botschaften aus einer anderen welt
ein engel packt ihn an den haaren und
entführt ihn in die lüfte
der flug führt zu einem schlachtfeld
plötzlich fährt ein zweiter engel mit
flammendem schwerdt vom handy nieder und
schlägt einem vornehmen ritter das
geschlechtsteil
der traum erschüttert karl er begreift
ihn als göttliche warnung
er soll sich von sexuellen
ausschweifungen fernhalten
wer sie bei seinem vater erlebte und
fortan ein keusches leben führen
die moderne psychologie deutet solche
kastrations- ängste häufig auch als
versagensängste man vorsichtig sein
ob man solche deutungen auf das 14
jahrhundert übertragen kann aber ganz
offensichtlich ist dass karl der vierte
unter einem sehr mächtigen vater und
einem sehr schwierigen gegen könig litt
und dass diese erfahrungen in seine
frühe königszeit hineinragten
das schicksal com karl zu hilfe
sein gegner ludwig der bayer
gibt sich vital und übermütig
doch im oktober 1347 fällt eher einem
schlaganfall zum opfer
selbstherrlich hatte ludwig den päpsten
getrotzt
nun denken viele zeitgenossen gott
persönlich habe ihm gefällt
mit dem tod des bayern wendet sich die
politische lage zugunsten des böhmen
karls gegner im reich sind jetzt ohne
führung doch statt gegen sie in den
krieg zu ziehen knüpft der könig zarte
bande
er heiratet anna von der pfalz eine
tochter aus der verwandtschaft der
feinde der kuh spaltet das lager seiner
widersacher aber schafft am ende frieden
ich schenke dir so lebe mich die
menschen
den schönsten ist es nicht anders nur
noch das größere beute sie zu überwinden
nicht anders ist es bei den frauen
karl möchte nach aachen reisen dort in
der kapelle seines namensvetters karls
des großen
wenn er nach vorgeschriebenen ritual die
königskrone empfangen
nur wer hier gekrönt wird gilt als
rechtmäßige herrscher im reich
doch der einzug in die stadt stößt auf
ein unerwartetes hindernis
majestät
ich bringe schlechte nachricht welche
nachrichten wie geißler weilen vor der
kirche
sie nehmen alles unter beschlag warum
darf der sie nicht dass der stand das
wagt niemand die menschen haben große
ehrfurcht vor den geist und vor ihren
könig haben sie keine
dem könig bleibt nichts anderes übrig
als vor aachen zu warten
in der stadt vollzieht sich ein düsteres
schauspiel eine prozession von geißler
sieht durch die gassen mit peitschen
fügen sie sich selbst schmerzen zu um
die leiden jesu nachzuempfinden
33 tage lang entsprechend den
lebensjahren jesu verlassen männer und
frauen haus und hof und buße zu tun
regelmäßig peitschen sie sich
gegenseitig nach festgelegten ritual
öffentlich aus
allmächtiger warte aber abendlichen
farbe sondern und erlöse und von unserer
scheint eine makabre darbietung in fast
allen städten des damaligen reiches
der klerus war sinnlos die pepsi galten
als geldgierig die menschen suchten
daher nach ganz persönlichen
ausdrucksformen von frömmigkeit formen
die die kirche ihnen nicht mehr an bord
sie schlossen sich in allen möglichen
formen vereinen von ryan zusammen
aber dies führte auch zu derartigen
exzessen wie wir sie in der geißler
bewegung greifen können
erst nach dem abzug der geißler ist der
weg nach aachen frei
am 25 juli 1349 wird kann nach alter
tradition gekrönt
auch seine gegner unter den fürsten
sollen ihm nun respekt
jetzt endlich ist er der von allen
anerkannte könig der deutschen
bei seiner krönung stiftet er für den
schädel karls des großen ein goldenes
reliquiar
das gesicht der büste zeigt einen
energischen und klugen mann das
idealisierte bild dass karl der vierte
von sich selbst entwirft
doch weder der könig noch sein reich
kommen damals zur ruhe die natur hält
immer neue katastrophen bereit eine
plage die man heute in europa nicht mehr
kennt sucht damals die länder nördlich
der altenheim
wann der heuschrecken
bis zu einer milliarde insekten in einem
einzigen schwarm musi einfallen bleibt
oft eine wüste zurück für menschen des
mittelalters ein unfassbarer schrecken
herrschten auf es ist schrecklich der
jüngste tag ist gebrochen die ganze welt
ist voller heuschrecken das ist das ende
karl ist schockiert und fasziniert
zugleich
er möchte dem phänomen auf den grund
gehen und reitet mitten in das flirrende
insekten her
später erinnert er sich der schwarmer
sieben meilen die länge und seiner breit
aber nicht zu überschauen
ein ungeheures tosen und ein gewaltiger
gestank gingen von ihm aus und sie
vermehrten sich denn zwei erzeugten 20
des nachts und noch mehr
die menschen des mittelalters hatten
keinerlei vernünftige erklärungen für
diese elementaren ereignisse sie kannten
aber sehr genau die biblischen schriften
dort war zu lesen dass heuschrecken oder
überschwemmungen als strafe gottes zu
beurteilen wären oder gar als vorboten
des jüngsten gerichtes deshalb lösten
diese naturkatastrophen ungeheure ängste
bei den menschen aus
vor allem die angst vor ewiger
verdammnis
die qualen der hölle wo die sünder im
feuer rasten sind für die menschen des
mittelalters so real wie die welt die
sie mit ihren augen sehen
doch der glaube bietet auch trost er
verheißt die große hoffnung auf ein
ewiges leben im paradies
dabei sollen die heiligen helfen denn
sie gelten als persönliche fürsprecher
bei gott
in der christlichen welt wurden daher
immer schon ihre sterblichen überreste
verehrt sogenannte reliquien knochen
zähne haare oder dinge die mit ihren
körpern in berührung kamen
karl ist auch kind seiner zeit wie
besessen lässt er in ganz europa
tausende reliquien aufkaufen
manche stifte der kirchen und klöstern
viele werber in seiner nähe haben
jetzt hat das ist dass schädel bei der
heiligen barbara ein wertvoller schatz
sie bewahrt gegen feuer und frau weber
wir werden ein schönes gefäß für sie in
auftrag geben
kann der vater war ein so berüchtigt da
reliquien sammler dass die kirchen bei
kaiser besuchen ihre türen verschlossen
und manchmal sogar behaupteten sie
könnten sie nicht mehr öffnen wie das
etwa magdeburg der fall war
wegen der berüchtigten liebe des kaisers
für diese reliquien verfehlte der lieber
geld für reliquien ausgibt als für
waffen bringt dem reich frieden doch
1348 zieht in den städten einer
katastrophe herauf die alle früheren in
den schatten stellt
ihren ursprung hat sie in einen albtraum
aus dreck und gestank
die menschen teilen den engen raum mit
schweinen und anderen haustieren in den
kasten verpassten fäkalien die luft in
dem schmutz fühlen sich die ratten wohl
in lager sind überall
und die tiere bringen tödliche gefahr
die pest erstes anzeichen ist eine
verdickung der lymphdrüsen wird der
erreger eingeatmet breitet er sich in
der lunge aus und führt in wenigen tagen
zum tod
die menschen sind eher solche hilflos
ausgeliefert
niemand ahnt dass ein einziger flow bis
das ende bedeuten kann
das ende durch die pest
max von pettenkofer institut münchen
inter panzertüren lagert zu
wissenschaftlichen zwecken
millionenfacher tod viren und bakterien
auch der erreger der pest er sie nie ab
esstisch benannt nach seinem entdecker
dem schweizer arzt gesehen
der krankheitserreger zählt zur gruppe
der bakterien einer der schlimmsten
killer der menschheitsgeschichte
übertragen wird er durch den ratten floh
der von den infizierten tieren auf den
menschen überspringt durch den fluss
gelangt das bakterium in die blutbahn
der pesterreger ist mit schiffen über
die krim gekommen die dann den
pesterreger also als schiffs hatte
sozusagen nach genua getragen haben und
dort sind diese ratten von bord gegangen
das waren dann wanderratten die die pest
erreger besser vertragen können als
unsere haus hatten und haben von da aus
dann für eine ausbreitung der pest über
ganz europa gesorgt
in mainz und köln sterben im jahr 1349
an manchen tagen mehr als 100 personen
die ärzte kennen die ursache der solche
nicht aber sie machen beobachtungen die
nützlich sind
sie bemerken dass die krankheit durch
kontakt mit anderen menschen und sogar
deren kleidung übertragen wird
sie empfehlen die häuser der toten
auszuräuchern wäsche und hausrat zu
verbrennen
dort den wütet der schwarze tod über
zwei jahre lang im reich
wie durch ein wunder bleibt prag von der
epidemie für schulen 1 1 kriegen aber
ich komme gerade aus dem reich zurück
ich sagt inge die unvorstellbar
furchtbar waren so ist das war was man
sich von der pestilenz erzählt dass sie
schlimmer wütet als früher viel
schlimmer majestät die menschen sterben
wie die fliegen manche stehen am morgen
gesund auf und liegen abends oft in
trotha nieder
ich sah mutter die aus furcht vor der
pest ihre kinder im stich ließen jeder
versucht seine haut zu retten
viele priester haben ihre gemeinde
verlassen die menschen sterben ohne die
tröstende kraft der sakramente und
fallen der verdammnis sein ein kind wenn
die ursache dieses stürmt die doktoren
der pariser universität behaupten
die ursache des übels sei eine besonders
unglückliche konstellation der gestirne
jupiter saturn und mars der allmächtige
schütze uns
hilflose erklärungsversuche die den
kranken nicht helfen
die solcherart ein drittel der 14
millionen deutschen dahin
die auswirkungen dieser sterberate sind
fundamental sowohl auf die wirtschaft
derzeit als vor allen dingen auch auf
die mentalität der bevölkerung
man muss sich nur vorstellen dass es für
uns bedeuten würde wenn innerhalb
weniger wochen 20 30 oder 40 prozent der
bundesdeutschen bevölkerung plötzlich zu
tode kämen welches leid das bringt und
welche auswirkungen das auf die
überlebenden kann ist in der nähe von
prag eine burg errichten
im zentrum baute er eine kapelle ihre
wände sind mit edelsteinen und blattgold
ausgekleidet oft sie sich der könig
hierher alleine zurück es ist sein
privates refugium in den stürmen der
zeit
du hast unsere böhmischen lange vor dem
pestilenz bewahrt
und uns damit ein zeichen deiner gnade
gewährt zu bitten wir dich
sägen auch weiterhin unsere werke
und wir uns auf dem rechten weg
an
während das reichen chaos versinkt
wächst das goldene prag in den himmel
eine insel des wohlstands in einer
apokalyptischen welt
karl gibt eine brücke in auftrag die bis
heute das wahrzeichen der stadt ist ein
technisches meisterwerk sei erzählt
und er macht sich einen namen als
förderer der wissenschaft die
gründungsurkunde der ersten universität
im heiligen römischen reich trägt das
wiegen karls des vierten
doch der glanz für den die prager karl
noch heute lieben ist ein glanz auf
kredit
majestät wir haben ein problem der
metzger weigert sich fleisch zu liefern
solange wir die ausstehenden rechnungen
nicht beglichen haben das brachte sich
könnte denn vertrösten tut mir leid aber
er lässt sich nicht mehr wo ich bin es
leid ich habe ganze städte verpfändet
ich habe irrtümer an bürger verkauft und
grafen zu prinzen gemacht aber ich kann
den metzger nicht bezahlen wenn ich der
könig der römer oder der könig der
kälber
die königin ist spätmittelalters war
notorisch pleite ihr steueraufkommen war
begrenzt
die großen fürsten herrschaften waren ja
eigene staatliche gebilde auf dealer
könig gar keine zugriff hatte konnte
also auch von dort keine steuern erheben
ihm blieben seine eigenen landes
herrschaften auch die städte die dem
könig unter standen und es gab eine
dritte einnahmequelle
das wort juden die juden sind die
außenseiter der mittelalterlichen
gesellschaft geduldet aber selten wie
kommen da ihnen der landerwerb untersagt
ist zieht es sie in die städte
zur zeit karls des vierten gibt es über
1000 jüdische gemeinden im heiligen
römischen reich
die meisten juden leben entlang des
rheins in basel straßburg speyer worms
mainz und köln
auch handwerker auszuüben verwehrt ihnen
die christliche umwelt so bleibt ihnen
nur der handel und das geschäft des geld
verleihen
das macht die juden zu einem notwendigen
glied der mittelalterlichen gesellschaft
aber sie sind neid und missgunst
ausgesetzt denn viele jüdische familien
bringen es zu beträchtlichen wohlstand
in den mittelalterlichen städten wie in
speyer wohnen juden gewöhnlich mitten im
zentrum wo auch ihre synagoge steht
doch die existenz der gemeinden ist
immer gefährdet und nichtige anlässe
können zum mord und totschlag führen
deshalb schuf der staufer friedrich der
zweite 1236 eingesetzt fortan standen
die juden im reich unter dem
persönlichen schutz der deutschen könige
und zahlten dafür steuern eine der
wichtigsten einnahmequellen der
herrscher dagegen ein tödliches gerücht
dass im reich umgeht ist der königliche
schutz wirkungslos unter folter sagt ein
französischer jude aus herbe duft in
brunnen geträufelt und so die christen
mit der pest infiziert
die nachricht verbreitet sich schneller
als die solche selbst
auch in gegenden die von der pest
verschont wurden allen bürger über ihre
jüdischen nachbarn her
pass und habsucht treiben die täter an
denn mit den juden vernichtet man auch
ihre schuldscheine schon ein
zeitgenössischer chronist aus straßburg
entlarvt den eigentlichen grund für die
pogrome alles was man den juden
schuldete galt als abgegolten wären sie
an gewesen so hätte man sie nicht
getötet
die jüdische gemeinde prags bleibt
verschont die mittelalterliche synagoge
hat die zeiten überdauert
karl der vierte verbietet übergriffe auf
die juden die er selbst in seiner
hauptstadt eingeladen hat als treue
steuerzahler
morgen sieht man sagt die juden hätten
die solche unter die menschen gebracht
aber die pestilenz güte doch in gegenden
wo überhaupt keine juden leben
das sagt sogar der papst dort wo sie
hütet fernseher selbst zum opfer die
juden können sich nicht beklagen sie
haben ihr leid selbstverschuldet wer
denkt doch es waren die juden die
unseren herrn jesus christus ans kreuz
geschlagen haben
aber sie sind meine schutzbefohlenen und
zahlen steuern dafür
und hier in prag kann ich sie schwitzen
aber in frankfurt wohnt speyer und ich
machen vor jede judengasse stellen
unsere schulen sind leer
auch in nürnberg bis die jüdische
gemeinde hingefahren
die stadt boomt und die bevölkerung
wächst daher beschließt der magistrat
den marktplatz zu vergrößern
doch dafür müssten dutzende jüdische
häuser abgerissen werden
die genehmigung dazu kann nur der könig
als schutzherr erteilen
der nürnberger gesamte ulrich stromer
wird in dieser angelegenheit bei karl in
prag vorstellig
platz zur pegnitz in er weiter an die
häuser stehen im weg und deshalb müssen
die juden häuser dort leider
verschwenden und wie will dir die juden
für die häuser entschädigen niemand hört
leben die juden zur zeit überall im
reich gefährlich sind die bürger für
nürnberg sich gegen sie erheben sollten
können wir auch wenn wir das bedauern
sie kaum daran ändern
es sind meine juden und meine häuser wer
sich darin vergeht vergeht sich an könig
nur für den fall dass das sondern eher
schaden nicht sein
eine juden stromer lieb und teuer
die vorgänge von damals sind
dokumentierte im nürnberger staatsarchiv
hat sich der vertrag erhalten
in karl der vierte mit dem magistrat
schlossen der könig gestattet den abriss
der jüdischen häusern
dafür verpflichtet sich die stadt an der
stelle der synagoge eine marienkirche zu
errichten
das dokument trägt unterschrift und
siegel karls des vierten was dort nicht
ausdrücklich steht aber impliziert es
ist dass zum zeitpunkt der ausstellung
in diesen häusern in die juden leben sie
sollen verschwinden das ist das was hier
unter der decke gesagt wird es ist eine
art freibrief fast zum pogrom
tatsächlich werden wenige tage nach der
ausstellung dieses privilegs die juden
von nürnberg
die 560 juden nürnbergs männer frauen
kinder werden zusammengetrieben und vor
der stadt verbrannt
den massenmorden während der festzeit
fallen fast sämtliche jüdische gemeinden
des reiches zum opfer
es sind die schlimmsten pogrome vor dem
in der nürnberger frauenkirche erinnert
heute ein davidstern an die ereignisse
des jahres 1349
und an das versagen des königs der
damals auch in anderen städten die juden
um seines vorteils willen preisgegeben
hat
man hat ihn vor einigen jahren den
ersten schreibtischtäter der geschichte
genannt
das ist eine erschreckend einer extrem
widersprüchliche figur und das zeigt
sich eben grad in seinem verhalten
gegenüber den juden juden seines eigenen
herrschaftsbereich es hat er in den
zeiten der pest 13 48 49 geschützt
in anderen gegenden sind sie zum
spielball geworden auch durch sein
agieren weil er letztlich die juden die
unter kaiserlichem und der königlichen
schutz stehen der königlichen kammer zu
gehören
preisgegeben hat und er damit auch seine
anhänger entschädigt hat
naturkatastrophen pest und pogrome haben
ungeheures leid über die menschen in
deutschland gebracht
der könig will dass nun ruhe in sein
reich einkehrt in nürnberg versammeln
sich auf initiative karls im november
1355 die kurfürsten zu einem reichstag
was er ein für alle mal festlegen möchte
sind eindeutige richtlinien für die
königs war
ohne den pfalzgrafen kann die wahl nicht
einberufen wird
daher wusste ich das geschrieben dass
ihr euch für unverzichtbar halten war ja
nicht anders zu erwarten so kommen wir
nicht weiter deutlich die rechte der
kirche in frage stellt es sind
schwierige verhandlungen
die gegensätzlichen interessen der
fürsten untereinander und der standpunkt
des königs müssen in einklang gebracht
werden
mit taktischem geschick und großer
zähigkeit gelingt es karl dem vierten
die kurfürsten auf klare regeln zu
verpflichten
in zukunft sollen drei erzbischöfe und
vier weltliche fürsten den könig mit
einfacher mehrheit wählen
das ist zwar schon gewohnheitsrecht
dennoch gab es unstimmigkeiten die jetzt
ausgeräumt werden
im januar 1356 sind die verhandlungen
abgeschlossen und das ergebnis wird
öffentlich verkündet
jedes reicht das in sich selbst zu
spalten ist wird vorn denn seine fürsten
sind gefasst über jahrhunderte immer
wieder zu konflikten führte ist jetzt
erstmals festgeschrieben
die aufteilung der machtbefugnisse
zwischen könig und fürsten im reich
kalle vater hatte erhebliches interesse
an einem geordneten einem stabilen reich
deshalb musste vor allem die königs wahl
eindeutig sein
dem diente das mehrheitsprinzip aber
auch die kurfürsten profitierten ganz
erheblich von den bestimmungen denn ihre
kur fürstentümer wurden als erblich und
als unteilbar erklärt ein gewinn also
für beide seiten als goldene bulle
abgeleitet von boula lateinisch für
siegel gehen die beschlüsse in die
geschichte ein
ein erstes deutsches grundgesetz 450
jahre lang bleibt es in kraft
seit damals bestimmen die erzbischöfe
von mainz köln und trier
der könig von böhmen der pfalzgraf bei
reihen der herzog von sachsen und der
markgraf von brandenburg
wer das reich regiert
an der nürnberger frauenkirche erinnert
noch heute eine uhr an den reichstag von
1356 zur vollen stunde definieren die
kurfürsten vor dem könig im gedenken an
karl den vierten und eine der
dramatischsten epochen der deutschen
geschichte
er war eine person voller widersprüche
und gab der nachwelt rätsel auf
hochgebildet fromm ein förderer der
wissenschaften und künste und doch hat
er sich nicht gescheut menschen zu
opfern um seine herrschaft zu wahren
in einer zeit des umbruchs karl der
vierte den deutschen eine neue
in der festgeschrieben wurde was das
land schon immer prägte selbstbewusste
regionen und ihre herrscher
keine metropole aber viele aufstrebende
städte
ein land aus ländern die sich immer
wieder trennten und am ende doch
zusammenfanden